la parole est notre collègue alain
gournac pour le groupe est républicain
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
monsieur le premier ministre les mois
qui passe que conduit d'étonnement en
étonnement devant l'absence de cohérence
d'une politique gouvernementale qui sont
guidés par l'improvisation et par
l'ambiguïté
nous entendons nous entendons monsieur
macron se répandent sur les ondes
expliqué au jour le jour
l' inverse de la politique que vous
menez sur le plan économique mais en
matière de contradictions
la façon dont vous allez conduire la
réforme constitutionnelle dépasse
l'entendement
madame taubira garde des sceaux conteste
publiquement le bien fondé de la réforme
que vous proposez tout en expliquant que
seule compte la parole du chef de l'état
cette situation ubuesque ne fait que
confirmer la contradiction au sein du
gouvernement en qu'une ministre de la
justice qui prône le laxisme judiciaire
et les annonces de fermeté que vous
multipliez à l'endroit des délinquants
tout cela conduit à un affaiblissement
inquiétant de l'autorité de l'état
ne pensez vous pas monsieur le premier
ministre la cohérence et la vertu
qu'attendent les français de leurs
couverts de leur gouvernement
et quel est le gage de l'efficacité de
son action
chez le premier ministre monsieur le
sénateur alain gournac en janvier
dernier nous savons tous parfaitement
malheureusement notre pays a été
lâchement frappé par le djihadisme par
l'islamisme radical par des terroristes
qui s'en sont pris à nos valeurs
fondamentales et en novembre dernier le
xiii s'est une nouvelle fois notre mode
de vie nos valeurs notre jeunesse qui
ont été sauvagement attaqué et se
souvenir celui des victimes de blessés ô
combien nombreux de leurs familles nous
devons tous le garder
en mémoire et nous devons agir pour eux
et pour combattre le terrorisme
les terroristes ont frappé la france et
nous avons riposté au levant bien sûr en
intensifiant notre action militaire face
à des ch en france en décrétant
immédiatement l'état d'urgence et en
prenant encore davantage de mesures pour
assurer la sécurité des français moyens
supplémentaires pour nous forces armées
pour la police pour la gendarmerie et
pour les services de renseignement et
nous avons pris ensemble d'ailleurs les
mesures qui s'imposaient avec grand sens
des responsabilités parce que c'est ce
que les français attendent de nous les
récents événements survenus au
commissariat de la goutte d'or dans les
viiie arrondissement à paris
l'agression antisémite qui a eu lieu
lundi à marseille nous rappelle
d'ailleurs en permanence l'intensité
inégalé de la menace elle n'a pas
disparu et je veux rappeler qu'il s'agit
pas uniquement d'un problème français
s'agit pas seulement d'un problème
européen
les attentats de istanbul ou de djakarta
revendiquée par l'état islamique
revendiqué par des ch en sont
malheureusement les nouvelles
démonstrations
le 16 novembre dernier devant le
parlement réuni en congrès c'est-à-dire
devant la nation que vous représentez le
président de la république annoncé en
plus de l'engagement à l'extérieur ou à
l'intérieur une révision de la
constitution afin d'assurer la
protection et la sécurité des français
dans la durée vous le savez mieux que
quiconque monsieur le sénateur vous
étiez présent il l'a fait parce qu'il
faut asseoir dans la constitution l'état
d'urgence et il l'a fait à travers cette
proposition de déchéance
parce que plus que jamais nous devons
revendiquer ce qu'est le patriotisme que
les français eux-mêmes revendiquent tous
les jours en chantant la marseillaise ou
en brandissant les couleurs nationales
il est temps en effet que nous soyons à
l'unission du peuple sur ces questions
alors dans ces circonstances dans ce
contexte face à l'intensité de la menace
moi je le dis je ne céderai pas l'heure
n'est pas à la polémique et l'heure
n'est pas aux petites phrases inutiles
le président de la république il l'a dit
le 16 novembre m'a chargé en tant que
premier ministre de préparer et de
présenter la révision de la constitution
vous connaissez le contenu de ce texte
depuis son adoption en conseil des
ministres le 23 décembre dernier
vous savez aussi jeune et annoncé à
l'assemblée nationale et je le redis ici
monsieur le président du sénat nous
présenterons également les textes de loi
qui doivent accompagner cette révision
constitutionnelle parce qu'il est tout à
fait essentiel que le parlement vote en
connaissance de cause
ce texte je le présenterai devant vous à
l'assemblée et au sénat
il n'y a pas de nouveauté je ne crois
pas d'ailleurs qu'il ya eu d'objection à
l'époque lorsque michel debré en 1963
pierre bérégovoy en 1992 jean pierre
raffarin en 2002 où françois fillon en
2008 ont présenté des projets de loi
constitutionnelle alors moi je ne
céderai pas à la polémique
christiane taubira est pleinement
investi dans la tâche qui est la sienne
elle partira devant le parlement dans
les prochaines semaines avec les
ministres de l'intérieur et des finances
un projet de loi ambitieux de réforme de
notre procédure pénale et je pense que
nous aurons aussi l'occasion de discuter
ensemble de la proposition loi qui est
porté par vos collègues bas et mercier
elle le fera comme toujours avec le
talent et la détermination qu'on lui
connaît le débat sur la révision
constitutionnelle doit désormais avoir
lieu au parlement le gouvernement il
prendra toute sa part et je sais que le
sénat aura à coeur de garantir la
sécurité des français et les droits
fondamentaux et face au terrorisme il
n'y a pas de place pour la division et
vous pouvez compter sur ma totale
détermination et moi j'ai la conviction
que cette prévision
avec tous ces aspects sera votée par une
très large majorité du parlement et que
la révision constitutionnelle pouvoir
avoir lieu
tout simplement parce que les français
n'attendent pas autre chose que de nous
l'union le rassemblement et l'efficacité
merci monsieur le premier ministre
gournac monsieur le premier ministre
vous ai écouté avec attention et où il
avait été sur un terrain qui n'est pas
éloigné du mien mais c'est pas du tout
le cas il ya encore trois quatre jours
on nous a dit que c'était madame taubira
qui sera ici côté elysée la presse je
voudrais porter les journaux moi je vais
vous dire monsieur de poésie il semble
que vous n'ayez pas réussi à convaincre
madame taubira
il semble que madame taubira n'a pas
réussi à vous convaincre
il semble que sa politique pénale n'est
pas réussi à convaincre ni les français
ni vous même
ni même le président de la république
c'est dramatique pour la france monsieur
le premier ministre votre réponse ne
nous a pas convaincus l'ambigüité
demeure
j'avoue rappellerait mes chers collègues
et monsieur le premier ministre pour
quoi bulle du cardinal deux res on ne
sort pas de l'ambiguïté qu'à ses dépens
tu échoues vraiment exceptionnellement
monsieur le sénateur et en priant de
vous excuser parce que je dois me rendre
ensuite à l'hommage qui est rendu à à
pierre boulez je veux uniquement vous
répondre même si vous avez de bonnes
citation non en effet n'a pas réussi à
me convaincre que les choix du président
de la république n'étaient pas les bons
ce sont les bons et quand le président
de la république s'exprime devant le
parlement réuni en congrès il scelle un
pacte un serment avec la nation et comme
premier ministre comme chef de
gouvernement et pas seulement parce que
je respecte les institutions de la vème
république n'est pas profonde conviction
ce texte je le porterai jusqu'au bout
parce que j'ai la conviction qu'il sera
adopté et il n'y a que cela qui
internautes français et monsieur le
sénateur conclut cherchons pas les
petites divisions mais au contraire
évite utilisant cela pour conforter le
rassemblement
merci